the Ukrainian flag has been raised in
the strategically important city of
Hesson following Russia's announcement
that its troops have completed their
withdrawal rotten troops occupied hair
salon not long after the invasion began
in late February and in September
President Putin formally declared the
region part of Russia while the flag was
raised by civilians soldiers as well as
officials in the region say Ukrainian
forces are close to retaking the entire
city Sky News has verified that this
footage was filmed today outside the
police headquarters in the city of
herself
well as ukrainians celebrate what could
be the full liberation of another region
it's reported that the White House is
pressing both sides to resume peace
talks Sky's Alex Rossi has spent the
morning in liberated villages in the
Hesson region he's now in Mcleod and can
join us live so big developments Alex
today what have you witnessed
yes significant development and a
humiliating loss really for Vladimir
Putin and Russian forces the situation
that we understand in person is pretty
fluid at the moment certainly has been
confirmed by the ministry of Defense
here that Ukrainian forces are now
moving in we've seen those those images
Euphoria celebrations in a central area
of Curson City and it's taken really
what eight months and this is the third
humbling defeat really for Vladimir
Putin in this uh War this boxed Invasion
uh
continuing to be liberated as the
Russian forces run away desert their
posts Retreat however you want to to
call it I was in villages earlier this
morning I was speaking to people who'd
literally been living in hiding really
for the last eight months or so they
were coming out they greeted us uh they
were tearful in many cases but they were
also extraordinarily happy that they had
now seen Ukrainian soldiers and they had
been liberated another interesting thing
that we saw as well we were taken by
Ukrainian soldiers who showed us huge
amounts of ammunition that have been
left by the Russians the suggestion of
course is that they left very much in a
hurry now the reports that we are
getting from Kirsten and the area around
the banks of the river suggests that
there may still be Russian forces inside
certainly officials here are saying that
they believe that there are Russian
soldiers who've changed into civilian
clothing and they are worrying about now
acts of uh sabotage so the situation
potentially extremely dangerous the
other thing that ukrainians are very
suspicious of is the fact that it may be
something of a trap as well remember
that the coordinates for all of the big
Junctions the buildings many of the
areas inside Curson City where when the
armor pushes in Ukrainian forces May
congregate that has now been sort of
lodged really with Russian Artillery so
that they can easily be hit but
certainly a very significant moment in
this war a significant loss for Vladimir
Putin and the the soldiers that we've
been speaking to today they say that
they have momentum and this isn't the
end they believe that they can move in
and take Crimea and other areas that
they have lost to Russian forces